[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact werner forssmann
a 25 year old doctor in germany had a
radical idea he proposed a new way to
examine the human heart and his idea was
flatly refused by hospital
administrators forstman's innovative
idea was to send a thin catheter through
a vein or artery directly into a living
pumping human heart and have a better
look around it was revolutionary for
1929 in a superiors thought this kind of
experiment would kill a patient but
Forsman was convinced that by combining
the catheter placement with an x-ray
physicians could detect human heart
problems earlier and save lives
foresman was determined to try so when
his bosses said no the young doctor
decided to move forward anyway he
persuaded a young nurse to unlock the
cabinet of catheters and to allow him to
do the procedure on her but he tricked
her while she was strapped to an
operating table he instead stuck the
catheter into his own arm she screamed
for him to stop but he went ahead anyway
then with the help of the same panicked
nurse Forsman walked down a flight of
stairs with a catheter in his heart and
persuaded a very reluctant technician to
take an x-ray he had made medical
history then of course the hospital
fired him but marginalized by the
medical community for years forstman's
bold experiments were studied by other
scientists who advanced this technique
and ultimately revolutionized medicine
in 1956
dr. foresman was working in another
hospital when he received a phone call
and was told that he had won the Nobel
Prize for his innovative work on heart
cos Asian even today with our incredible
medical technology nothing can see or
repair the human heart the way God can
this is why david prayed search me O God
and know my heart stay with his friends
were going to learn more on this edition
of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor
hello listening friends this is Bible
answers live we are a live international
interactive Bible study very excited to
do the most wonderful thing in the world
talk about the Word of God and how to
live forever I can't think of anything
more important than that talk about what
the plan of God is for our lives and to
understand his teachings and if you have
a question about the Bible or living the
Christian life we invite you to give us
a call we have several lines open right
now here's the phone number 800 God says
that's 800 for six 372 97 one more time
800 God says 800 for six three seven 297
we'll bring your Bible question into the
studio here in Northern California and
we also have free resources that we give
out during the program so keep your
pencil handy we'll be giving you some
websites where you can watch ongoing
Bible studies and tonight pastor Ross is
off but we're gonna launch into our
program with prayer father in heaven
thank you very much again for your
blessings and Lord for the truth you
said thy Word is truth and that's our
focus of study tonight so be with us
Lord pray that your glorified and all
that we think or say we ask in Jesus
name Amen you know I can see several
times in the Bible where it makes it
pretty clear that Jesus was gone because
the Bible tells us in second Kings that
God and God only knows the thoughts of
men's hearts only God knows what you're
thinking
in your heart sometimes a person might
look at you and by your expression they
can make an educated guess of what
you're thinking but only God can really
look into the human heart and know
exactly what you're thinking better than
you do and several times in the Bible it
says Jesus
knew what was in man Jesus knew what
they were thinking you can look for
instance in mark chapter 2 Luke chapter
9 here's one in Luke 9 verse 46 an
argument arose among the disciples about
which of them was the greatest but Jesus
knowing the reasoning of their hearts
and then he addressed this with him so
many times Christ knew what they were
thinking God even knows what you want
before you pray but he tells us to pray
because it does good to us when we pray
and what conversion is is a change of
heart
the Bible says being born again is being
given a new heart
that's what conversion is all about
would you like to have a new heart
friends and by God tells us that he'll
make us new creatures he says the new
covenant is I'll put a new heart within
you we have a free study tonight it's a
beautifully illustrated to get pictures
through it and some great scriptures and
and reasoning in Bible studies we'll
send it to you free it's called a love
that transforms how do you get that new
heart just call the resource line this
is another phone number you ready
it's free eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven if you'd like this
free Bible study a love the transforms
and after you read it and you give your
heart to the Lord you give it to someone
else
eight hundred is the phone number eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven just tell them you're listening to
Bible answers live with that we're going
to go to the phones again we do have
several lines open if you dial and it
rings for a minute just give our
operators a chance to pick it up that
number 800 God says eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven brings
you into the studio alright gonna go to
the first call talking to Stephanie
Stephanie you're on the air with Bible
answers live hello how are you tonight
I'm doing great how are you some good
things I'm calling from Albuquerque New
Mexico and I had a question about
predestination both in Romans 8 and
Ephesians 1 specifically verse 4 and 5
were in the New King James that reads
just as he chose us in
him before the foundation of the world
that we should be holy and without blame
before him in love having predestined us
to adoption as sons by Jesus Christ to
himself according to the good pleasure
of his will then down at 11 and 12 it
says in him also we have obtained an
inheritance being predestined according
to the purpose of him who works all
things according to the counsel of his
will
that we who first trusted in Christ
should be to the praise of his glory so
my question is now you were just not
reading from Ephesians or Romans you
gave me two verses that was verse four
and five and then switch them to chapter
one
okay chapter one okay I just want to
make sure we're looking at the the same
verses so are you wondering it does this
do these verses mean that God decided in
advance who was going to be saved yes
this is a common misunderstanding if you
look at what is happening here in the
time of Paul many Gentiles non-jews were
learning about God and learning about
Jesus through the Apostles that we're
teaching to them and many of the Jews
that were in Rome and Ephesus were
Paul's writing we're hearing from the
Jewish converts well God chose the Jews
that were his chosen people and they
they were almost leaving them feeling
like that they the Gentiles were
second-class and Paul is saying to the
Gentiles no God chose us also way back
it was God's plan the gospel should go
to all the world it wasn't just for the
Jews and so people have misunderstood
and thought God has arbitrarily said
ahead of time I'll save this person and
not that person but that wouldn't make
sense because the Bible says God would
have all men to be saved and then you
can read in 2nd Peter chapter 3 oh you
you read it like it's like verse 8 does
God is not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance how many does he want to come
to repentance oh and if you read the end
of the Bible in Revelation this great
appeal it says whose
whoever will let him come and take the
water of life freely whosoever you know
John 3:16 whoever believes in Him might
not perish but have everlasting life
so everybody is free to come and if God
has pre decided who's gonna be saved why
are we doing mission work
you'll save who he's gonna save and
other the rest are all doomed if God
created so many people talking about
when they say predestined well that
means that God before the foundation of
the world had also planned that Gentiles
should hear the truth accepted that when
he says he's predestined us he means the
Gentiles he's right into in Ephesus in
Rome that we should also say now okay
I'll give you a little tip if you look
in Chapter three second Peter chapter
three Peter says well I think it's like
verse 15 he says Paul sometimes says
things that are hard to understand and
those that are unstable twisted to their
own destruction you'll never read James
Peter Mark Matthew Luke saying things
that leave us confused about
predestination they're all very clear
sometimes people hear what Paul says
when he's telling the Gentiles you have
also been predestined to be saved and
they think he's saying that God has
hand-picked a few people to be saved and
everyone else is just already Desa
destined to be lost that's not okay okay
all right thank you all right thank you
by the way I've got a free book I'll
send you if you'd like okay and it's
simply called
can a saved man choose to be lost if you
call our resource number can a saved man
choose to be lost
it explains predestination and the
number is 885 eight three five one
second you said 808 three five six seven
four seven six seven four seven football
they're standing by right now and
they'll send you the book okay thank you
thank you Stephanie appreciate your
patience all right with that we're going
to talk Nick
to David who's I think calling from
Sacramento David you're on the air with
Bible answers live uh hi pastor Doug hi
he said OK for us to eat turkey well now
I guess what you're talking about David
is is it okay for a a Bible believing
Christian because of the laws that are
found in Leviticus that say that you
should not eat certain unclean animals
like people shouldn't be eating skunks
Jannah beating vultures what about
Turkey is it in the category of the
clean or the unclean birds the clean
birds were the foraging birds now when
you look at the clean and the unclean
laws for a diet most people have no
problem with these laws you know people
don't typically eat the unclean foods
except you know among the animals people
don't eat camel but they do eat pork
people don't eat rats
that's one unclean foods but big problem
is typically pork among the fish if it
was seafood you were supposed to have
two things fins and scales problem there
is shellfish is unclean they're
scavengers pigs are scavengers vultures
a scavenger God did not want people
eating scavengers because it's very
unhelpful matter of fact the best diet
and everybody knows this today is a
vegetarian diet but God said look if
you're gonna eat meat eat the clean
meats these were things that could be
brought to the temple and offered and
among the animals that needed a cloven
hoof and to the cuts you've got a rule
for the fish fins and scales the rule
for the animals cloven hoof chews the
cud like a cow goat sheep so forth among
the birds it was to be a foraging bird
in other words the animals that go
around in the woods and pick seeds like
a chicken or a turkey or a dove
technically a pigeon people in New York
City will probably never star or starve
in a famine because it's plenty of
pigeons there those were clean birds
because they're they're foraging birds
they were not to eat the birds of
carrion are the the Raptors like eagles
and
and the vultures and things like that so
those are the rules for the animals
David and I hope that helps a little bit
we do have a lesson that talks about
what the Bible says about the clean food
and the unclean food and it's called
God's free health plan if you call our
resource number eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven we'll
send you a copy of God's free health
plan thank you for your call gonna talk
next with Michael who's calling from
Miami Florida hi Michael are things
drying out down there yeah actually no
powers being read access in a lot of
sessions but they're still some parents
are still in blackouts there's still a
lot of debris lying around so Herman
didn't hit it directly but it's a legal
market well I know what that's like I
was in Miami in 1964 when they had
hurricane or was it 65 Betsy and we gots
we were taking surfboards down the
street when I was a kid so I know what
that's like
anyway we're glad that you're uh you're
alive and well and your question tonight
so yeah my question is on how do you
know that is God talking to me you have
any thought in your mind because I know
that you know when when is a moral
thought you know we always have a Bible
as a guideline but I'm asking more in
terms of like you know questions that
you might prey on like uh-oh how do I
like I think God for guidance on whether
or not you should start get a certain
job or you know right if you're right
moral question how do you know that up
trot that your instead is in your mind
is of God or practice of your own your
own your own mind wandering yeah that's
a great question I tell you what let me
first before I answer the question I
want to tell you I've got a book I've
written I'll send you a free copy and
it's called how to know the will of God
and it covers the same principles I'm
going to share with you first of all the
best way to know of course is what does
the word say but sometimes you might be
saying Lord I'm choosing between two
paths that are okay two jobs I don't
know which one I'm supposed to do big
decision so how do you know what God's
will is how do you know if you're just
getting your own conscience or your own
feelings that are directing you was that
the voice of God there's several things
that when you put together yeah
several things you do one is of course
look at the word but then you also get
Christian counsel the Bible says in the
multitude of counsel their safety get
the advice of people you trust with good
judgment sometimes you'll have the
leading of the Spirit just your you'll
have a desire in your heart that you
feel is leading you
sometimes that's placed there by God
that Psalms 37 says he'll give you the
desires of your heart so sometimes got a
place a desire in you for the thing he
wants you to do sometimes you'll see
providential things happening you know
you're thinking of going somewhere and
all of a sudden there's a hurricane well
that means you can't go maybe that was
God telling you no so pardon the pun but
there's so there's providential things
that happen and so you start putting I
think I've got like 12 things in the
book ways to know and recognize the
voice of God or the will of God you put
them together and you can make a pretty
good judgment sometimes you simply need
to be patient and keep listening you
know what I mean yeah so most important
most dependable is make sure you have
scriptural backing for what you think
the voice of the Spirit is guiding you
sometimes a person says all the Lord
told me and you and I know God doesn't
speak audibly to very many people
right it's usually a strong impression a
person might have that through their
conscience the Holy Spirit is speaking
to them and there it seems real but it's
it's usually within so send for that
book determining the will of God and
we'll send you a free copy and the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
ask them for Doug's book on the will of
God 808 three five six seven four seven
thank you for your call Michael let us
free up another line if you have a Bible
question pick up your phone give us a
call right now and with that we're gonna
go talk to James who is calling from
Delaware James you're on the air with
Bible answers live those how you doing
tonight I'm doing better than I deserve
how are you I'm doing the same thing
Saint think my question is
how was the old st. Abraham and knowing
all of Howard they saved well that's a
great question the bible says that
abraham believed god and god counted it
to him for righteousness that's way back
in the book of Genesis so it goes pretty
far back they were saved by faith in the
Lamb of God do you remember the story in
the Bible where Abraham was going up the
mountain with Isaac and God had told him
to offer his son and all the way up the
mountain Isaac says father you know
Abraham hadn't told him what they were
doing yet he's his father we've got the
the makings for the fire and we got the
wood where's the lamb and Abraham said
my son God will provide himself a lamb
and of course that was sort of a double
statement God provided a lamb upon the
hill but Jesus provided himself as the
Lamb of God John the Baptist pointed to
Jesus when Jesus came to the Jordan and
said behold the lamb of God that takes
away the sin of the world so in the Old
Testament they were saved by faith who
looking forward to the Lamb of God
that's every time they offered a lamb or
a goat they were looking at the day when
the Lamb of God would come we are saved
by faith looking back at the cross to
the Lamb of God
so everybody is saved by Jesus nobody is
saved by works nobody is saved by Buddha
or Muhammad the only way anyone can be
saved is by Christ you still there yeah
that makes sense yeah all right so yeah
all the patriarchs were saved by faith
and you would also appreciate the lesson
that we're offering to others tonight it
talks about being saved by faith and
getting that new heart it's called a
love that transforms if you'd like a
free copy of that it's called eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven ask for the study a love that
transforms and we appreciate your call
James again that opens up a line wow we
got lots of lines open if you want to
get to your Bible question in tonight
maybe you've had some biblical conundrum
that you've been wondering about then
pick up the phone here's that number
again to reach the studio with your
Bible question some question about
living the Christian
life or the Word of God 800 God says 800
for six three seven two nine seven one
more time 800 for six three seven 297
give us a call and we are live I'm gonna
go next and talk to Maria who's calling
from Redding California Maria you're on
the air with Bible answers live yes
hello hello this is Marla Omar I'm sorry
it said that I just I looked at the two
quickly okay I had a question about
Daniel 2 verse 43 because it's
meaningful to me since it's in the days
of these Kings that God sets up a
kingdom and whether that's the judgment
of the righteous dead being the rock
coming up out of the mountain or what
but so let me read you mo to read this
for people who are driving yes okay cuz
yeah we've got probably 80% of those
listening or maybe in their cars or
working around the kitchen they don't
have a Bible at their fingertips and it
says in Daniel chapter 2 and I'm gonna
read you said verse 43 I'll I'll back up
to verse 42 and as the toes of the feet
were partly iron and partly clay so the
kingdom will be partly strong and partly
brittle and as you saw the iron mixed
soft with soft clays so they'll mix with
one another in marriage but they will
not lay hold together just as iron
doesn't mix with clay is that the verse
you're wondering about correct yes well
let me give you something to think about
each did the angel comes and explains
the Daniel or the holy spirit explains
to Daniel what the interpretation of
this dream is and he tells the head of
gold represents the kingdom of Babylon
silver Persia bronze the Greek Alexander
the Great the iron is the feet of iron
and clay are the iron legs is Rome the
iron and clay is a mixture of the Roman
Empire with religion they iron is Rome
the clay is like religion and what you
have during the Dark Ages you get the
mixture of the Roman Kingdom that sort
of then transitions into
a quasi Christian Roman Kingdom but
something else that's very interesting
is the number one building material in
the world today is iron mixed with miry
clay it's called concrete around the
world
there's building and springing up
everywhere and they're made if you've
probably seen them pouring concrete
before and what they do is they put
reinforced iron they dump the concrete
on top of it you get iron mixed with
clay
how would Daniel explain that to King
Nebuchadnezzar way back you know five
hundred years before Christ
so we're living in the age of iron and
clay right now and we're living in the
age where you've got the division of the
European kingdoms the ten toes represent
the divisions of the Roman Empire it
ended up becoming it sort of became the
Holy Roman Empire and yet Catholicism
and the King you had religion and the
breakup of the Roman Empire were ruling
Europe and then that has then since then
broken up and spread around the world in
South America they speak Spain Spanish
because that was one of the kingdoms of
Rome and Brazil they speak Portuguese
because Portugal was one of those
divisions of Rome in America they speak
English because the Saxons were one of
those divisions of Rome see what I'm
saying and Canada they speak French so
the divisions of this Roman Empire
spread around the world the whole world
uses a Roman calendar today okay you
know that's where the reason we got a
month called July is after Julius Caesar
in August is Augustus Caesar so the
Roman influence spread around the world
and we're living in the age of the
divisions of the Roman Empire and go
ahead okay oh I so appreciate this and
I'm mainly focused on that really helped
that really help the first part of the
first they mingled seed among themselves
and I wanted to ask you if Maria Teresa
Habsburg being you know married in 1736
she's the only one that didn't
interbreed and she had like 16 children
and she told them all who to marry and
they all married kings and queens
I'm just thinking could that be relating
specifically to a certain time period
well you're on the right track it wasn't
just Maria that you mentioned at one
time Queen Victoria of England was
related to just about every head of
Europe through marriage and so what they
tried to do is when the Roman Kingdom
broke up they tried to create peace in
the former provinces through
intermarriage so they intermarried the
kings and queens and that's where you
get the word Blue Bloods some of them
their genetics were so bad through
intermarriage that they had hemophilia
and they called them the Blue Bloods but
it didn't work
they couldn't weld together the Kingdom
Charlemagne tried to reunite the Roman
Empire as did Kaiser Wilhelm and Adolf
Hitler and Napoleon and they all failed
so they did it through intermarriage
through war and we're living right now
in the time of those kings you know
we've got a great Bible study that talks
about Daniel chapter 2 we'll send you a
free copy if you like and it's called
the Millennial man it's historical
lesson and if you ask for our historical
lesson on the Millennial man we'll send
you a free copy of that Marla and I
think you'll find that a blessing that
number 883 five six seven four seven
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven do you still have lines open
that number to call in with your Bible
questions is 800 God says that's 800 for
six three seven 297 I'm going to see if
I can start on another phone call before
we get to our break so we're gonna talk
to David in New York David you're on the
air with Bible answers live I'm doing
wonderful how can we help you tonight
okay pastor I have a question I watch a
lot of like sermons on YouTube and
offense for minds in church they text me
you know good stories and all of that
and I do spend quiet I do spend time in
the Bible I get up at 5:00 or so and I
do spend time in the Word of God but I
feel that the Lord wants me to send more
but it seems like I can't get over that
bridge
so you're wanting to know how do I spend
more time with God and are you going to
church also yes well tell you what I've
got a few good suggestions for you that
may help you may already be doing it but
if you don't mind standing by for just a
few moments David when we come back
after the break you're going to be first
in line of the phone calls and we're
gonna talk about some ways that you
might be able to feed more on the Word
of God and get over that bridge that
you're talking about how's that sound
can you hold on for me that's great
all right hey you stand by and we'll
start out with David when we come back
want to remind our friends before we go
to our break that we have a great
website and amazing facts has incredible
Bible study information YouTube's videos
other study links simply amazing facts
dot o-r-g check it out don't go away
coming back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts has impacted me I praise
God for amazing facts amazing facts
actually did have an impactful process
getting to where I am today
I began reading the Bible I got baptized
into his death I realized that there had
to be moral and he's really doing this
the life that he's coming this message
was psyched out I swear he goes amazing
facts more than 45 years of proclaiming
God's message around the world and in
the logo pops across amazing facts
presents I've listened to a lot of
different ministries with him this was
the first time that he's actually saying
something where I had to grab my Bible
and actually pick it up and I've never
heard this before let me let me look
through and find this that I just
couldn't get enough and so I started
doing Bible studies every single one of
these guys started being changed
including myself my question was why did
that happen to me God the Lord was able
to reach out and I actually saw him as a
father I lost everything and that was
when I realized that it was gone missing
in my life I went to a prophecy seminar
which knocked me out this message was so
powerful and so irrefutable
I just went this is real this is this is
amazing
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
now let's join pastor Doug Batchelor for
more Bible answers live welcome back
listening friends to Bible answers live
and we are live we do have phone lines
open if you have a Bible question we
invite you to pick up the phone give us
a call 816-756-3580 way pilgrims
progress have you read the book
steps to Christ yes that's another
wonderful book well it sounds like if
you know the Bible promises if you draw
near to God he will draw near to you and
something I found I'm just sharing with
you things I have found that helped me
get some biographies of great Christian
leaders and read the biographies about
their
versions and you're gonna find that
you're inspired by what inspired them
and so you know if you read you know
some of the writings of you find some of
the great Christians and you know John
Newton who wrote amazing grace
incredible testimony you can read that
will I think encourage you the story of
David Livingstone and a number of others
some of the testimonies bring to life
how others found great victory in Christ
and I found you know encouragement with
that and then in your prayer life I just
you know having a list of things that
you pray about and not only praying and
talking to God then listening and oh god
Spirit speaks to you but you know we
have to go to the amazing facts website
we've got a number of materials and
devotions and videos there that I think
you'll also find a real blessing and so
we'd encourage you to try that as well
thank you very much David and I hope
that helps I'm now gonna go to the other
David David you still there I'm sorry
about the false alarm earlier glad you
hung on how are you doing well and your
question tonight yeah so my question is
from second Timothy chapter 4 verse 14
can I read it real quick please yeah so
Paul's writing to Timothy and it says
Alexander the coppersmith did be much
harm made the Lord repay him according
to his works yeah and so this question
has and it's been bothering me for quite
some time because you know Jesus says
forgive seven times or is it sometimes
seventeen right and and you do you think
based on this verse there's ever a
chance that someone can do so much harm
to us either because they're resisting
the gospel or for whatever reason where
we can say I rightfully can say before
God made the Lord repay you according to
your you know according to all the evil
that you've done to me you know that's a
great question when you read the Psalms
and I've wondered this myself you know
I'm not on this program because I claim
to have all the answers
King David sometimes in the Psalms he
seems to call down wrath on his enemies
he says you know let their table be a
snare and he says all kinds of very
direct things now David if so no David I
mean if if you look at the David in the
Bible I got a lot of David's around me
tonight we look at the David in the
Bible and he forgave King Saul who tried
to kill him twice he had an opportunity
to get even and he won it so you knew
that David had a real heart of
forgiveness but he would sometimes pray
that wrath would fall on his enemies
usually because they were hurting the
people of God Paul actually is not
praying for Wrath the Fallen Alexander
the coppersmith it's believed that
Alexander the Cockrum coppersmith had
something to do with Paul B and
re-arrested in Rome and you know he
ultimately was beheaded for this and he
didn't say God get even with him because
Paul is the one who said don't do evil
unto your enemy but overcome evil with
good Paul's the one who said that
actually Paul is quoting Solomon - he
says the Lord will repay him according
to his deeds he's just stating the fact
jesus said everyone is going to be
rewarded according to their deeds Paul
is not saying oh I hope God gets even
with him I think Paul was kind of sad
saying it he says the Lord will repay
him according to what he's done okay
he's not really calling a curse down on
them if you asked Paul would you rather
have Alexander converted or condemned
he'd say converted okay but there is a
time you know in the Bible where you
just know that though you kind of need
to put something in the devil's hands
and and because they've turned their
back yeah yeah perfect all right here
well thank you very much appreciate your
question David and with that we're gonna
talk next with Robert who's calling from
college place Washington Robert you're
on the air with Bible answers live Oh
pastor Doug hi thank you for calling yes
my question is regarding John chapter 5
verse 24 and we believe that in
Revelation
I think it's 14 verse 6 where there's
supposed to be a judgement going on but
then Jesus says that people won't be
judged if they hear their word if they
hear his word and believe in him now let
me read this for people listening in
John chapter 5 verse 24 24 truly truly I
say to you that whoever hears my words
and believes him who sent me has eternal
life he does not come into judgment but
has passed from death to life well
there's several different phases of
judgment when the Lord comes one is what
you would call the pre-advent judgment
that's where Peter says judgment must
begin at the house of God so Peter does
say there is a judgment for the house of
God people who profess to be believers
you also find a reference to that in
Ezekiel 9 then there's a judgment during
the 1000 years where the Saints are
basically participating in a judgment
and then you've got the final executive
judgment it's sometimes called the white
throne judgment where the wicked are all
gathered before the Lord and they're
there executed according to their works
the righteous don't have to fear the
executive judgment because when we
accept Christ our names are entered into
the book of life and this is why Jesus
said you know if you accept him he if
you hear my word you believe it you have
eternal life now there are some who
outwardly professed oh yes I accept you
Jesus but then during the the
investigative judgment it's found
they're frauds they're the ones that are
saying Lord Lord but there you know that
works the Bible says we're saved by
grace but we're judged by our works
their works don't show that their hearts
been changed
yea they will come into that last
judgment because they aren't the ones
who are really believing so those who
really believe Christ for the Jew to
believe doesn't mean to just acknowledge
to believe means to be live you believe
it you act opponent
those who are really be living in Jesus
they have passed from judgment into life
they have nothing to fear from judgment
see because during the pre-advent
judgment we're not there are we no we're
not standing before judgment bar crisis
our representative so we pass directly
from our death into the resurrection and
so I think that's what Christ is talking
about we have nothing to fear of the
executive judgment okay does that make
sense now right so let me just back up
when the Lord comes
is he distributing rewards good or evil
in other words when he comes to saved or
saving the lost or lost right correct
so some investigation takes place before
he comes does that make sense yeah okay
that's what's known as the pre-advent or
investigative judgment the one that
Peter refers to when he says judgment
begins at the house of God but then the
righteous have nothing to fear from the
great white throne judgment that you
find in revelation that you spoke about
so we're not the books are that's what
Jesus is talking about there yeah we've
already been with the Lord for a
thousand years in heaven why would he
judge us and then say Oh up I made a
mistake I got to take you out of heaven
okay
alright see so alright hey we do have a
lesson I'll send you a free copy and
it's called facing the judge and all
you've got to do is ask for that and
thank you for your call Robert by the
way that does free up another phone call
if somebody would like to give us a call
Oh for that lesson that I just mentioned
to Robert called facing the judge if
anyone wants to better understand the
judgment call 808 three five six seven
four seven eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and if you
have a Bible question call 800 for six
three seven two nine seven again if you
want to call in with a question to the
studio 800 God says 800 four six three
seven two nine seven still have room
lines open and time left in the program
gonna talk to Ronald calling from New
York Ronald
on the air with Bible answers live about
some demonic phone calls I begin if
those talks about Ephesians 30:13 we
started out against principality of ours
yeah seasons 613
yeah we're wrestling not against flesh
and blood but against principalities and
powers against rulers of darkness in
heavenly places yeah so there's good and
evil
yeah weird phone calls good night not
too long ago but I brought the phone
calls and the person will be talking the
person my roommate he answered the phone
and the person said tell Ronald this is
same than the person every time I will
answer the phone a person will be hisses
like a snake and they will keep calling
and if I would think some inappropriate
the phone will rain you know and you
know what you do you know what you're
doing the kids like that then okay wait
then things will be moved here knocks on
the door and then the phone call
Lorraine you know but I brought the
phone call you know yeah I just if if
first of all if someone's making a prank
phone call and hang up if the devil is
making a prank phone call hang up and
don't let don't let them mess with your
mind because the Bible promises greater
is He that is in you than he that is in
the world and then just well I want even
well you know what Ronald don't even
engage the person if if someone calls in
there whether it's a prank phone call or
whether it's a demon on the other end of
the line don't even talk to him there's
only one time that Jesus talked to the
devil in
conversation there was one question no
other time did he ever engage in a
conversation we should never do it none
of the disciples did that and I would
just hang up and just pray and say Lord
you know just put bring peace into my
heart and peace into my home and
overcome evil with good sing a holy song
you know just sing something encouraging
don't let the devil distract you with
those things and that you know he just
likes to harass you to even think about
it and so don't give the devil the
benefit and you're quoting the right
scripture is Ephesians chapter 6 and you
just resist with the armor of God now I
do have a free lesson I'll be happy to
send you Ronald if you're still there
the lesson is called the armor of God
and it I'll send it to you it's just
call this number free eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
it's a book I've written called the
armor of God it's easy it's a short
booklet 808 three five six seven four
seventy it will encourage you on how to
wage war against these harassing spirits
or whoever it is it's doing it hey thank
you so much for your phone call we're
gonna talk next with Susan he's calling
from Champaign Illinois and what are
your on line one Susan hello welcome oh
hi thanks for waiting
yes I would like to know if believing
Christian can ever lose their salvation
that's a good question now tell you it's
a big debate and there are good
Christians on both sides I want to be
careful to just make it very clear if
you were John Wesley who founded the
Methodist Church you would say yes a
believing Christian can lose their
salvation if you were John Calvin you
would say no once you're saved you're
saved if you were Luther you would say
yes you could lose your salvation if you
were George Whitefield you'd say no no
there are good it's a big debate on the
Christian assurance now the idea is you
you don't want to be thinking once
you're saved you always have to live in
fear what
I do something wrong will I lose my
salvation that's one danger that you
have no peace the other danger is that
you think that once I'm saved I can do
anything and I can't lose my salvation
that's presumption so you got the
tension between the peace and the
presumption the the fact is you do have
examples in the Bible that people are
people who were once spirit filled that
grieved away the holy spirit and they
were lost
King Saul is one dramatic example he was
actually a prophet at one point chosen
by God filled with the Spirit of God but
over a course of years it didn't happen
overnight he just continued to rebel
against God's Word became proud mostly
became jealous of David and he harbored
this jealousy and bitterness and ended
up killing himself and we don't expect
that Saul was saved the last thing he
does is he goes to a witch he gets
involved in demonism you've got Judas
who was an apostle Jesus sent him out
preaching teaching casting out Devils
and but you just just harbored the
spirit of covetousness and he won't let
the Lord deliver him now some would
argue Judas was never saved and that may
be but they need to have cases like a
prophet named Balaam Balaam was a
prophet of God but he and God used him
but he ended up getting covetous and he
kind of turned from following God to
chasing after a god of money and he was
lost so you've got examples in the Bible
where you need to be careful and even
Jesus says in Revelation he writes to
the church he says unless you repent
it's a message to the church I think the
Church of Smyrna that unless you repent
I will take your candlestick out of its
place and you know the Lord in all his
messages to his church he tells him to
remain the faithful he that endures to
the end there's a there's a message all
through the Bible about Christians
holding on
don't giving up the good fight of faith
and the implication is that it is
possible for a Christian to lose their
faith so that's why we've got a nurture
that relationship now having said that
Christians shouldn't be living in fear
every day that I'm gonna have an up-and
down relationship aren't saved today
lost tomorrow save today lost tomorrow
we need to have a faith that if we
continue to come to the Lord he will
never let go of us every day Paul said I
die daily every day Paul said I'm gonna
say no to self and yes to Jesus every
day jesus said take up your cross it's a
daily choice to say I'm gonna deny it
myself and follow Christ today and that
begins with prayer first thing in the
morning so I think the devil would love
to have people believe that once you
come forward in a church and you say the
sinner's prayer and you accept Jesus and
you know you may have the honeymoon with
the Lord for a little while then you can
do whatever you want and you can never
be lost I don't see that in the Bible
but you you said yourself people
shouldn't be afraid of maintaining their
salvation
but if I don't get up and pray and if I
do deliberately what I want instead of
what he wants and my been losing my
salvation if you continue to only do
your will and not God's will now let me
just tell you what Jesus said not
everyone that says Lord Lord will enter
the kingdom of heaven but they that do
the will of my father so doing God's
will is pretty clearly taught by Jesus
you can read where John says and this is
in the first letter of John chapter 2
verse 15 love not the world neither the
things that are in the world for If any
man loves the world the love of the
father's not in him for all that's in
the world the lust of the flesh and the
lust of the eyes and the pride of life
that the world and the world will pass
away in the lusts thereof but he that
does the will of God will abide forever
so yeah every day Paul says we got to
fight the good fight there's a wrestling
that happens don't be discouraged if
there's some effort involved in
Christianity the idea that there is no
effort is a myth you know Jesus is
pretty clear that you know that's why
Paul said you put on the armor of God
and you fight the good fight of faith
doesn't that become works more than
faith
well you're not saying it's a fight of
faith it's not a fight of works see the
difference if we're not doing the right
works there's usually a problem with the
faith and so it's really all about love
jesus said if you love me keep my
Commandments and so if we're struggling
with obedience it's often a love problem
and not an obedience or works problem
the more we love him the better we will
obey Him and so and the more you know
him the more you love him Bible says we
love Him because He first loved us right
yeah and so the more we look at the
cross we see how much he loves us we see
how much sin hurts him it makes us want
to do his will you know Susan the lesson
we offered tonight when we began the
program is meant for you I really hope
you'll take advantage it's a free offer
and it's a great lesson Bible study
talks about salvation and how to have
that assurance would you like us to send
you that free copy yeah all right all
you've got to do is make one more phone
call
nobody's gonna harass you or knock on
your door bother you and it's will
descend it to you the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and as for though
it's called a love the transforms how do
you have that assurance I love the
transforms I think you'll enjoy that
okay thank you all right god bless Susan
thank you for your call with that we're
gonna talk to Tammy calling from nobody
hit David again here let me see her
gonna go to there we are we had Tammy
Young here Tammy and Berkeley California
hi thanks thank you thank you very much
I love everything you do I love you guys
with program and I've learned so much
from the online Bible study or school
deliciously then we have Bible trivia
church I was nearly unstoppable thank
you such a wonderful hey how can we help
you Tammy what's your question yes
Michael
I'm always concerned about using the
Lord's name in vain
I know the we're not supposed to
absolutely it's very clear and the chain
command was about that I think it's the
third month yeah I'm always thinking
mister and but I was listening to the
radio my first show your show wasn't on
yet but it was another show and they
they said that like if you say oh my god
or gosh or stuff like things like that
that's using the Lord's name in vain I'm
like oh my gosh I've heard people say oh
Jesus Christ and I'm just like I I can
imagine if you say the GD word which I
know you need but you're wondering is
that taking the Lord's name in vain yes
the GD word I know that Cecily let me
let me address that for we run out of
time first of all not taking the Lord's
name in vain it means when you say
you're a Christian you take God's name
and so if you're gonna say you're
Christian and you don't live like a
Christian you're taking his name in vain
you see were to take a person's name in
vain means that you say I am I belong to
this person like used to be not so much
more as it used to be but a woman would
marry man she take his last name but if
she takes his last name and she runs
around with another man she's taking his
name in vain so that's one understanding
but it certainly does include that you
should never take the name of the Lord
in a and they used to make vows and
they'd make oaths and they make promises
and they'd use the Lord's name and you
should never use an or Lord's name in an
oath or of our promise and then break it
but then also it is certainly true that
we should never take the name of the
Almighty on our lips irreverently
and that's probably what this other
pastor was talking about and you know
without seeing the program I don't
exactly know but from what you said I'm
inclined to agree I don't like when
people say gee whiz
because that's a derivative of saying
Jesus name or they say gosh I know it's
a habit with so many people and I used
to have that habit when I first came to
the Lord and but don't worry the Holy
Spirit can help you break that habit but
you know it's whenever we're using an
experiment of like that Jesus and let
your yes be yes and your no be no we
don't need to say these things we're
we're you know not only directly taking
God's name in vain using this literal
name but even using derivatives of it so
I I agree I think that it's wrong I hear
kids and they're you know even in church
I hear kids say gosh and I kind of wince
and I say no what does that mean they
don't even think about it they don't
know what it means
but I say you try to educate them and
say that's a derivative of wanting to
say God's name in vain or some other
form of it you know people we have oh my
god yeah people say it on the news you
hear it on television every time I hear
it I kind of wince a little bit hey you
know I tell you what we're almost out of
time but I want to give you something
Tammy that I think will help you I wrote
a little book it's easy to read it's a
little book called the name of God it's
called the name of God and if you got a
pen handy Tammy you waited a long time I
want to send you a free copy just write
down this toll-free number 880 five six
seven four seven ask for the book the
name of God 808 three five six seven
four seven and I'll send you a free copy
and with that also you can probably read
that book for free online if you go to
the amazing facts website a lot of the
studies that we've offered tonight you
can also do for free at our website we
like to put the hard copy in people's
hands because then we know you're gonna
read it sometimes I give out web
addresses and it's too easy people don't
go online and do it but if you are
diligent person and you will remember
this web address can you remember the
words amazing facts just go to amazing
facts com org.net dot TV we have all
those domains it'll take you to one of
the best websites out there now I'm
feeling a little guilty because we
invited everyone
to call in and a lot of people called in
and I didn't get to all the calls now
dear friends can we still be friends
give me another chance next week in the
meantime do take a look at the website
amazing facts dot o-r-g help us stay on
the air
you can donate there online god bless
you Jesus is the truth that will set you
free thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion southeast Ohio betelgeusian Tian
Shan Djokovic I enjoy the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you I really
wanted to start a new devotional habit
but life got in the way next thing I
know we're a month into the new year and
I'm like what's the point of starting
then I saw 365 amazing answers to big
Bible questions each day is a single
study so you can start anywhere on any
day and not miss a thing their crisp
clear and enlightening get yours today
by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]